technology is moving language learning
forward the biggest thing in language
learning is input good quality learning
content and I just bought all these
books and they make false promises like
B2 if you take this Persian book of
Essie Mill or Turkish B2 of course
that's not true you need massive amounts
of input today with technology you can
find stuff on the internet you can even
find audio files upload them to link
it's transcribed you have a lesson it's
going to be better and better better
quality time stamping more accurate
automatic transcription the world of
language content is coming at us so that
our brain can start picking up the
language because the brain doesn't learn
the little details and the rules the
brain needs lots of stimulus to form its
own rules